all right now I want to pick out one
other result something similar to this
when you have a look at each one of
these do any of them stand out there's
more more interesting or more elegant or
more profound now the first one sort of
its paramount of this one so that's a
good argument okay but it doesn't say
anything in addition to this one like it
more or less says the same thing is this
except for some negatives there too okay
so I would say that in their current
forms none of these are particularly
more interesting than the others so I
want to play with one of them to
demonstrate actually there is something
more interesting happening the one I'm
gonna take is there's no way it's the
middle one okay now like I said I can
take any of these in fact I'll take the
bottom one and I'll show views but that
as well
but for now I think that we must direct
with the middle one okay so let me show
you the first thing I'm going to do is
you can see I've got it all ready to use
everyone's into the same ones into okay
I have the same order in here if all I
do is a tiny little bit of algebraic
adjustment okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to subtract said - I should
say the more is it true I'm gonna
subtract that from both sides okay so
here's what I get
okay all I've done is subtract mods into
from both sides okay now in order to get
that into something looks a little more
like this I'm just going to UM flip
around the inequality you see that so if
I put more on zebra - it's too bad the
modulus of the difference on the left
hand side then now my equality switches
around are you happy with that now how
would you articulate just like I
articulated here
how would you articulate this inequality
what is this in here yeah okay that I'll
gonna stop that same way and one of the
difference
so you can see how this line here we
just stated and I'll put a box around it
now I'm ready to use it
this statement is kind of like the
flipside of this guy right if you take
if you add up two complex numbers and
take care Mochis you get something less
than that individual moduli taken
separately if you subtract two complex
numbers interesting if you subtract two
complex numbers you get something bigger
than if you subtracted the individual
ones okay now if you remember I said I
could have taken this one I can take
this one as well you don't have to worry
about this but just watch I'll show you
if I do the same thing here right if I
go subtract to get the order thing
happening I'll get there to take away
set one on this side inequality is still
facing the same direction and then
you've got them one of the differences
there now if I switch things over the
inequality goes careful because the
order matters over here on the right
hand side and you look at that you're
like it's always right but it's not
quiet you see the order doesn't match
I've got one two and over to one except
for the fact that do you remember we
established this before
then when you think that has two value
right the order in which you subtract
things doesn't matter if you're taking
the absolute value because just a
distance it's always going to be
positive
does that make sense so therefore this
sky down here is really the same as this
so now I actually do have the order that
I want
in fact this statement is exactly the
same as this statement it's just that
I've just switched my labels around
wanted to what is 2 + 2 is 1 it's the
same inequality okay all right
sir excuse me I think that is what we'll
cover this lesson and I wake up here to
- to go a little bit further I guess the
thing I would highlight is on on aha
two things before you are dig into a
size 1.3 learn more on this before you
finished it number 1 see this said 1
plus n2 and this is n1 minus n2 business
right last time we saw how that was
something you could take advantage of in
a parallelogram did the diagonals of the
parallelogram right now it's same you
can form triangles with these things so
anytime you meet another question which
is complex numbers and you see them on
constitute or is there more - it's you
that's kind of like a dead giveaway that
you should be making some kind of
geometric argument you should be drawing
a diagram and try to figure out what
triangle is what parallelograms can I
take advantage of what you make sure
properties will be useful because this
is a geometric side right this is not
just some number hanging in the middle
of nowhere it's meant to be part of a
triangle or pilot parallelogram okay